[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 franche comté pour
une émission spéciale élections
municipales exceptionnellement france 3
vous propose deux débats en première
partie de soirée et ce tous les
mercredis aujourd'hui nous commençons
par lons le saunier et montbéliard et
c'est montbéliard qui ouvre la série
trois invités sur notre plateau pour
débattre durant 45 minutes
tout d'abord marie noëlle biguinet maire
sortante ait l'air de montbéliard façade
éric lançon socialiste qui conduit une
liste divers gauche ps europe ecologie
les verts pcf il est conseiller
municipal d'opposition également
conseiller régional dans la majorité de
la socialiste marie-guite dufay
à ses côtés denis sommaire il est député
du doubs tête de liste pour la
république en marche
ancien syndicaliste cgt il a été
notamment conseiller régional et maire
socialiste de grand charmont
alors pour commencer à vous trois une
seule et unique question pourquoi êtes
vous candidat à cette élection
municipale à montbéliard l'ordre de
réponse a été tiré au sort et c'est à
vous de commencer
denis sommaire bonsoir a tous écouté je
suis candidat montbéliard d'abord parce
que j'aime j'aime cette ville
passionnément
j'ai pas ce beaucoup tant depuis fort
leur fort longtemps
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que cette
ville vit une grave crise de confiance
crise de confiance venant parce que les
citoyens ne comprennent pas forcément où
la ville les emmène c'est vrai dans tous
les projets urbains crise de confiance
des des commerçants qui comprennent pas
quelles sont les politiques qui sont
menées les problèmes d'animation de la
ville
la préparation de début est donc j'ai
constitué l'une une équipe pour répondre
à toutes ces problématiques
marie-noëlle biguinet vous êtes la maire
sortante ait l'air pourquoi vous
représentez vous bien bonjour à toutes
et à tous et bien maire de montbéliard
depuis 2014
nous avons fait avec mes collègues élus
beaucoup de choses pendant ces six
années il reste encore évidemment
beaucoup de choses à faire
c'est un métier entre guillemets
passionnant que d'être mère j'aime cette
ville dans laquelle je suis né où je vis
j'aime les montbéliardais et bien sûr
avec les mambé liardet pour les grands
milliardaires je souhaite continuer les
nombreux projets que nous avons éric
lançon
bonsoir depuis 37 ans j'ai appris à
connaître la ville le pays de
montbéliard
j'aimais les habitants après les avoir
connus jeu je vois une ville qui se
recroqueville une ville qui se divisent
voire même une ville qui à certains
moments s'immobilise je vois également
une ville qui souffre 25 % des habitants
souffrent de cette politique actuelle du
gouvernement jeu est le candidat tout
les montbéliardais quels que soient leur
quartier leur âge leur profession je
veux évidemment que montbéliard trouve
sa place on a dans la culture
l'industrie le commerce l'économie et il
faut que nous travaillons tous ensemble
pour cela alors autres candidats
présents donc pour le premier tour de
l'élection municipale à montbéliard
franck plein qui conduit une liste
loutre du tout vriet il nous dit lui
aussi pourquoi cette candidature
je suis ouvrier chez psa et j'ai la
charge de conduire la liste lutte
ouvrière fin on tremble quand des
travailleurs pour la troisième fois sur
montbéliard s'est uni ce qui est
composée de travailleurs de
travailleuses d'intérimaires d'employés
de professeurs de toutes les catégories
qu'on peut trouver dans le monde du
travail
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est que
la situation du des travailleurs se
dégrade de plus en plus
on fait un tour des quartiers et que ce
soit montbéliard ou dans les autres
villes cdu c'est du pareil au même
et tout ça parce que justement les
politiciens qui sont au gouvernement où
qu'ils soient des notables locaux sont
au service du grand patronat donc
l'intérêt de cette campagne c'est de
faire entendre
seul et les intérêts de ceux qui ne
vivent que de leur travail
il est 21h n 9 minutes et depuis deux
minutes le couvre-feu règne sur le
quartier de la chiffogne à montbéliard
madame le maire c'est vous qui avez pris
cette décision alors petit rappel des
faits le quartier de la chiffogne ces
deux mille habitants dimanche et lundi
des dégradations ont lieu feu de
poubelle incendies de voitures donc à
partir d'aujourd'hui les jeunes de moins
de 16 ans doivent rester à la maison
entre 21h et 7h du matin et ce jusqu'au
8 mars
marie-noëlle biguinet pourquoi cette
décision et bien parce que depuis
quelques jours une dizaine de jours je
voit et nous voyons nous élus la
situation et l'ambiance dans ce quartier
se dégrader grandement vous avez parlé
effectivement d'ascendis de voitures de
feux de poubelles mais aussi de
containers à poubelles qui sont proches
des habitations et deux ans des
immeubles et qui mettait bien sûr la vie
des habitants qui pouvait mettre la vie
des habitants en danger vous accusez
même vous avez dit dans la presse des
adversaires politiques de faire monter
la pression
vous visez qui alors je ne vise personne
en particulier mais monde en général
mais il est certain que l approche des
élections municipales et suite à une
réunion de quartier qui a eu dans le
quartier de la chiffogne qui sait pas
forcément très bien passé les choses se
sont très rapidement dégradé
donc on m'a donné on va donner la parole
si vous voulez bien
éric lançon vous en pensez quoi de cette
décision mais moi j'ai déjà condamné
toutes les violences
le droit la sécurité c'est le premier
droit de tout le monde donc il faut qu'à
montbéliard ces droits sont respectés
à partir de là la décision en incombe à
madame le maire moi je suis déjà étonné
que
au mois de juillet eu de nombreux
problèmes à la petite hollande dans
d'autres quartiers
cette époque de ville avait posé un
couvre-feu couvre-feu pas la ville de
montbéliard
donc je suis assez surpris que deux
semaines avant les élections cela arrive
le deuxième point c'est que vous mettez
en cause gt gt touchés comme les mis en
cause indirectement parce que c'est
depuis donc la réunion publique qui a
mal tourné c'est la vôtre
non pas du tout elles n'encourent pas
fait voilà non ma réunion publique une
fois fait et dans toutes les réunions
publiques
on discute on échange il ya de la
controverse comme dans la vie de tous
les jours
moi je suis je n'oublie pas que la
police était de pouvoir régalien déjà
donc obligatoirement je m'adresse il
sans doute revient aux députés pour dire
qu' il manque des effectifs de police la
loi de finances même si elle a
légèrement augmenté le budget pour
permettre je t'aime moi non par rapport
à la décision de madame le même genre
pensez quoi
mais c'est justifié ou c'est pas
justifié c'est justifié l'ice tea mixte
est justifié alors après est ce que
c'est une prévention ce que vous c'est
une sanction elle après je ne suis
absolument pas contre le couvre-feu
je m'interroge sur le moment et je
m'interroge aussi sur des mesures
d'accompagnement parce que là c'est une
sanction de nice au maire vous en pensez
quoi de cette décision couvre feu à la
chiffogne écoutez c'est un terrible
constat d'échec fois qu'on en arrive à
prendre une telle décision me paraît
être véritablement un échec
c'est la preuve d'une certaine
impuissance et j'ai envie de vous dire
madame licence et échec 2-2 de la mer ne
l'aï pas du tout j'ai envie de vous dire
avant de mettre sous cloche le quartier
rallumer la lumière parce que quand même
dans les quartiers vous savoir qu'à
partir d'une certaine heure y'a pus de
il ya plus de lumière si les policiers
veulent intervenir
il faut qu'ils interviennent avec lampe
de poche quand on veut assez assurer la
sécurité dans des quartiers qui à un
moment donné peuvent poser difficulté la
première chose qu'on fait quand même
c'est de ne pas éteindre la lumière et
si vous dites ça fait dix jours ou
quinze jours qui a déjà décrit ya des
difficultés il fallait je pense réagir
avant et moi je m'interroge quand même
sur la pertinence des politiques qui
sont menées dans sept qui sont menées à
montbéliard quand même est-ce qu'on va
passer advitam eternam toutes les
vacances scolaires en mettant le
quartier sous cloche alors répondre
c'est plus inacceptable enfin va faire
répondre madame begin et donc on sera
pas qui quels adversaires politiques
vous visez et donc en fait est ce que
c'est une réponse disproportionnée pour
quelques feux de poubelles je pense que
c'est sachant que le thème de la
sécurité c'est un thème cher au
rassemblement national qui ne présente
pas de liste sur votre ville mais est ce
que cette décision ne peut pas être vus
quand même comme une petite manoeuvre
électorale alors non je pense que la
manoeuvre électorale qui consiste à dire
que c'est la première fois qu'il y à un
couvre-feu à montbéliard est faux faute
puisqu'il y a eu un couvre-feu à
montbéliard
l'an dernier il y avait eu des couvre
feux dans de nombreuses villes de
montbéliard à savoir grand charmant où
vous étiez maire pendant de nombreuse de
nombreux jours et qu'il y a eu un
escadron de gendarmerie qui est venu
pendant une dizaine de jours sur gand
charmant et sur bethoncourt après de
multiples problèmes donc les problèmes
d'insécurité ne sont pas réservées à la
ville de montbéliard
vous le savez parfaitement et vous
essayez de botté en touche sur ce
couvre-feu qui n'est pas une sanction
mais qui est une prévention pour éviter
que les choses ne s'aggravent et ces
jeunes de moins de 16 ans ils doivent
rester chez eux pendant le temps le soir
dans la journée peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent évidemment mais le soir s'ils
mentent mettre le feu aux poubelles ah
oui bien sûr bien sûr mais entre 21h et
7h je pense que avec eux le la
dégradation de l'ambiance sur ce
quartier c'est une manière de les
protéger et pas du talent instructions
de nice oh merde vous avez été attaqué
en tant que représentant de
de la majorité en place sur les
effectifs de police etc
vous répondez quoi donc tout d'abord on
ne peut pas comparer les deux situations
puisque l'année dernière qu'est ce qu'on
vivait on vivait la coupe d'afrique avec
eux on sait bien des risques de voile à
des difficultés dans un certain nombre
de quartiers en ville on n'en est pas là
il s'agit pas de cela aujourd'hui ce
dont il s'agit c'est deux feux de
poubelles de quelques voitures qui ont
brûlé et moi je comprends l'exaspération
des habitants concernant d'ailleurs les
rues mon quartier j'ai pas de laquelle
vous parler mais toutes les mairies en
carrière quartier se sont super bien
passé donc mais où doit quand même
reconnaissez avec moi qu'on peut pas
passer toutes les vacances scolaires de
cette manière et que donc un moment
donné ça peut pas être que la faute des
autres et il faut s'interroger sur les
responsabilités en données comparables
convives dans la ville
et puis une corriger ce qui est
nécessaire enfin on ne peut pas en
permanence dire c'est la faute des
autres ça c'est pas possible
est ce que je peux répondre juste en
prêt vous n'êtes jamais ce que j'ai dit
à un moment que c'était la faute des
autres je les oublie ça
non quand je le sous préfet vous avez
interpellé monsieur le sous-préfet ont
disons qu'il n'était pas intervenu comme
il fallait des courses police
aujourd'hui la presse à hawaii mais
alors la presse c'est une chose je sais
parfaitement ce que j'ai fait ce que
j'ai dit je n'ai jamais dit que c'était
de la faute des autres par contre les
forces de police nationale est le nombre
de policiers qui sont de moins en moins
nombreux à montbéliard et sur le
territoire de la circonscription avec
des problèmes de sécurité qui s'aggrave
et vous le savez parfaitement on nie
toujours qu'il ne dit toujours qu'il y
assez de police nationale mais c'est
complètement faux pourquoi de nombreuses
villes en france et moi j'ai beaucoup
apprécié et il me semble que vous êtes
des républicains monsieur lanson et du
parti socialiste denis sommaire conduit
une liste la république en marche j'ai
l'impression mois que quels que soient
les partis qui ont été au pouvoir ils
ont baissé des forces de police nicolas
sarkozy le premier oui alors bon
d'accord oui non mais aujourd'hui nous
sommes en deux
20 je parle pas de nicolas sarkozy moi
je parle de ce qui se passe mais vous
diront oui link vous avez dans la ville
il ya eu au moins deux postes depuis
cette année si ble ment ça a été le cas
de tous les gouvernements depuis un
certain nombre d'années sur le lieu où
ils ont baissé le nombre de policiers
dans les villes
le dernier mais peu importe aujourd'hui
la situation est ce qu'elle est nous
sommes en 2020 et il faut qu'il y ait
une véritable réaction pour que le
gouvernement et le ministère de
l'intérieur apporte la réponse qui doit
être la sienne puisque je vous rappelle
que la sécurité c'est une mission
régalienne aller real en son amour oui
un mot pour ramener sur le terrain de
montbéliard moi j'ai souvent interpellée
en conseil municipal depuis cinq ans
madame le maire sur la politique dans
les quartiers en 2014 par exemple vous
aviez décidé de fermer le gymnase
brossolette
je trouvais ça injuste tout pourquoi
injuste parce qu on obligeait des
associations à traverser toute la ville
pour aller sur un autre quartier je
trouvais ça injuste parce que c'était
elle c'est un quartier politique de la
ville parce qu'il ya de nombreuses
associations et c'est un lieu qu'il
fallait conserver et vous avez fait de
nombreux investissements je voulais dit
également chaque fois on conseil
municipal où on al'impression vous êtes
la mère du centre ville et ça dans les
quartiers ils ne l'acceptent pas mais je
vais quand même finir sur les
investissements parce que ce n'est pas
des paroles en l'air tout simplement
pour dire que les investissements
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ont eu lieu
essentiellement au centre-ville
je suis pour les investissements au
centre ville mais on peut pas oublier
les quartiers est ce qu'on est en train
de vivre actuellement c'est
malheureusement la conséquence d'une
politique qui est en difficulté vous
l'avez déclaré sur france bleu par
exemple vous avez dit oui il est vrai
qu'ils manquent des avis des activités
pour les enfants de 15 à 17 ans vous
faites vous même ce constat d'échec ou
la prévention la sanction et la
réparation doit être une chaîne
là on est tous les maillons doivent être
présents on écoute la réponse de madame
biguinet alors je vais reparler du
gymnase brossolette ce gymnase a été
fermé parce que la majorité socialiste
du département à l'époque en 2004 a
décidé de fermer un collège et le
gymnase afférents au collège
été fermées dans la prolongation de la
fermeture du collège c'était naturel et
les choses étaient ainsi ce sont vos
amis politiques qu'ils ont décidé
d'aller le mensonge est extraordinaire
quand on continue à grand-charmont même
situation le gymnase est resté ouvert
mais en fait je vous dise qu'il sait pas
s'il faut la petite hollande ce qui
s'est passé sur la petite hollande à
montbéliard un collège ferme et le
gymnase qui dépend pour dire que le
gymnase est resté ouvert
non mais non mais il faut qu'on ait un
débat la vérité aussi à ce que vous
portez comme propos tout à fait
réducteur sur le manque d'activité que
j'aurais dit pour des enfants
enfin des jeunes à partir de 15 ans
c'est essentiellement sur la chiffogne
où j'ai dit que nous devions et que nous
pouvions améliorer les choses tout mais
autrement nous avons énormément d'offres
d'activités pour les enfants et pour les
jeunes et vous le savez fort bien on va
justement parler un peu du centre ville
je suis désolé monsieur lançons
justement de la redynamisation du centre
ville
peut-être aussi des transports
montbéliard monsieur lançons c'est la
ville de l'automobile ça vous a pas
échappé dans votre liste ya des
écologistes et si vous est élu maire de
montbéliard est ce que vous allez bannir
la voiture du centre-ville mais c'est
bien on va vous avez bien fait de venir
vous révéler on ne mettra surtout pas ça
mon programme
même les écologistes qui roulent en
voiture et aucun souci non simplement il
faut que toutes les mobilités soit
présente sur la ville de montbéliard et
dans l'agglomération le transport urbain
donc les nouveaux les nouveaux
transports en commun j'ai voté contre à
l'agglomération je suis d'ailleurs parmi
nous 3 le seul à avoir voté contre parce
que j'estimais qu'il mettait la ville de
côté ce n'était pas un plus aucune plus
value de ce transport pas de nouveaux
pas nouvelle voie en site propre pour
par les articulations du théâtre au
niveau de service est en place depuis la
fin 2018 est un peu honte d'un star
actuellement que c'est un échec 200
millions d'euros 107 millions sur un
fonctionnement 4 bientôt 100 millions
sur l'investissement
on s'est encore rendu compte madame dit
gainey peut en témoigner au conseil
d'agglomération aucun changement des
mobilités ça veut dire qu'il ya pas plus
de trafic on va répondre madame diguiny
en 20 secondes là dessus pour vous ce
nouveau service de transport c'est un
plus sous ses pas en plus alors je suis
assez partagé parce que il a amené dans
les villes qui sont traversés par se
transporte une certaine améliore
amélioration de la qualité des espaces
publics
je pense par exemple à audincourt à
montbéliard par exemple la rue de la
chief qui est une rue qui n'avait vu
aucun travaux depuis 60 ans a été
complètement modifiée et restructurer sa
porte donc un plus
néanmoins sur le nombre de personnes qui
prennent les transports en commun il est
vrai que ça n'a pas augmenté que c'était
essentiellement des publics scolaires
qui sont donc des publics captifs et qu'
il y a même eu dans certains quartiers
évidemment je parle de montbéliard une
dégradation de la qualité du service
quand je parle qualité du service c'est
il faut faire plus de distance à pied
pour rejoindre une ligne de nice au
maire vous êtes en retard en temps de
parole est ce que vous voulez vous
exprimer sur l'histoire des transports
publics
est-ce que vous avez des propositions à
faire si vous êtes maire de montbéliard
mais je pense que les il ya une
réflexion à poursuivre sur la question
du des tarifs voilà parce que je pense
que les tarifs sont encore trop élevés à
la fois pour les jeunes un euro c'est
pas comme ça on peut penser que c'est
pas grand chose en réalité c'est
extrêmement important à nos yeux c'est
le prix mix et prix de ces le prix d'un
ticket et puis il faut s'interroger sur
les personnes âgées etc pour avoir des
politiques tarifaires que soit beaucoup
plus incitative et notamment aussi pour
les étudiants
voilà quelque chose comme 130 euros pour
l'année c'est quand même significatif
après il faut faire le bilan réel de ce
qui est
de ce qui s'est passé le fait d'avoir
fait passer le le ths en plein milieu en
face sur la rue de lachine
à mon avis était une erreur pourquoi
parce qu'on a coupé en réalité le centre
ville en deux on a éloigné
en fait le tout le secteur de la
sous-préfecture de la rue de belfort et
de la rue piétonne et on a installé en
réalité dans dans la ville une fracture
je pense que c'est une erreur
on va donner la daronne vu le point de
vue du fonctionnement du commerce et je
pense qu'ils sont vous vous prenant mais
vous proposez vous carrément la gratuité
des transports pour savoir combien
si vous êtes mère alors une gratuité col
alors la version qui pour cela on est
bien mais quoi alors progressivement on
va déjà commencer par les étudiants et
les jeunes qu'on vient de dire denis
sommer parce que à terme vous voulez que
ce soit gratuit pour tout le monde
à terme bien sûr pour l'essence et la
seule solution qu'on peut avoir à terme
financièrement c'est 11% des recettes
actuellement les la billettique donc
déjà sur 500 ventes de billets finances
11% seulement du budget fonctionnement
des transports la falla et pour revenir
l'argument porté par monsieur denis
sommer c'était justement l'argument que
je que je défends des pour voter contre
parce que ça n'apportait rien la vie de
santé la rue de la cheville que madame
le maire met en avant aucune piste
cyclable par exemple ouverte unième
siècle c'est-à-dire ces trois millions 1
je crois aucune piste cyclable on quand
on parle de mobilité c'est bien une
approche globale qu'on doit avoir des
mobilités donc lui vers une gratuité
progressive parce que dunkerque par
exemple c'est une grande réussite et
actuellement on a ce trajet pour 40 à 50
ans je ne vois pas les solutions pour
augmenter le trafic voyageurs gratuité
ou pas gratuité pour vous je pense que
c'est un dossier qui mérite qu'on s'y
penche sérieusement et qu'on fasse la
comparaison avec d'autres agglomérations
qui pretty pratique déjà cette gratuité
parce que si mes renseignements sont
bons justement sur l'agglomération de
dunkerque dont la gratuité a fait
augmenter le nombre de participants de
voyageurs mais en même temps comme il y
à des pertes de
sept qui sont non négligeables et bien
il y à une baisse de l'investissement et
du remplacement des matériels qui roule
c'était aussi bien les bus que les
abribus ou le toute l'infrastructure
tout et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait hésiter
quoi absolument parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'il ne faut pas traiter à la
légère parce qu'autrement vous avez des
équipements qui vieillissent qui
vieillissent mal qui tombe en panne qui
coûte de plus en plus cher avec des
abribus qui parfois peuvent être
dégradée on n'a plus envie de s'y
arrêter donc on ne prend plus le bus etc
ces deux points de ce dossier
fonctionnement et investissements
doivent absolument être gardés ensemble
alors dans cette partie transports
publics écologie environnement je vais
vous m'avez dit que vous envisagez pour
les cantines un repas végétarien dans
toutes les cantines de la ville
oui comme en écho kelkoo alors pourquoi
commandes et bien dès la rentrée
scolaire prochaine nous sommes en train
de travailler d'ailleurs sur le cahier
des charges il y aura la possibilité de
choisir soit un repas végétarien soit un
repas classique
nous sommes en train de voir le coût que
cela représentera pour la collectivité
on est en train de construire le cahier
des charges est ce que pour vous c'est
un signe d'être écolo de faire un repas
végétarien mais ils ont tout le monde
vers 10 son programme alors mais on a
choisi d'être acquise écologistes parce
que quand on a un problème de garde des
sceaux map avoir un peintre va vers les
écologistes tout simplement est donc
évidemment saint saëns végétariens comme
les circuits courts comme le bio mais
derrière cela quand on dit cela 100 %
bio ou de produits locaux on sait bien
qu'il faut construire toute une filière
derrière ce que tout le monde va
s'engager là donc vous travaillez avec
les obligatoirement avec l'agriculture
avec les circuits courts
il faut que l'état également il faut que
légalement soutiennent l'agriculture bio
parce que actuellement c'est plus que
trois ans c'est à dire quand on joue on
change l'agriculture un compte on passe
d'une agriculture intensive à une
agriculture bio les agriculteurs n'ont
plus que trois ans de soutien donc c'est
difficile parce que le bio nécessite
évidemment des frais supplémentaires à
faire répondre on va faire répondre
denis sommer sur cette question là
l'agriculture bio
soutenez ou pas mais par le passé j'ai
mis en place une restauration scolaire
dès le départ on a mis en place le choix
entre un repas végétarien avec le plus
de produits bio possible et puis un
repas ordinaire pour une raison toute
simple c'est moi j'ai des petits-enfants
je sais comment ils mangent parfois ils
mangent de la viande parfois ils en
mangent pas mais ce qui m'importe c'est
que les gamins il est chaque fois un
repas équilibré et donc si mon équipe si
je suis élu il y aura vous aussi vous
faites de l'école et je les ai déjà fait
je l'avais jamais justement quand on
porte trop tôt porte l'étiquette la
république en marche et que nicolas
hulot par exemple a quitté le
gouvernement avec les glyphosate etc
c'est pas difficile de faire cohabiter
écologie lrm va pas du tout bah écoutez
c'est mais pratique
moi je vous dis j'ai dû mettre une
restauration scolaire en place dans ce
grand 2003 ou 2004 je ne suis plus trop
ces été mis en place dès le départ donc
voilà je me suis je les fais par
ailleurs bien évidemment que je le ferai
à montbéliard par contre on a dit rond
mais que du bio me paraît quand même un
petit peu hasardeuse pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les filières sont
pas suffisamment organisés alors il ya
certes les aides de l'état mais il ya
aussi les aides de la région pour
accompagner la transition des
agriculteurs de verre vers le bio est
aujourd'hui la question c'est la
structuration réalité des filières
l'organisation dit boucher
l'organisation des restaurations
collectives pour que ça ça fonctionne
c'est qu'on est devenu voir le pouvoir
d'un air invité jacques pélissard maire
de lons le saunier qui a organisé ça
depuis des années à l'échelle de de
l'agglomération de lons le saunier c'est
une grande réussite
ce dont on a souffert au cours des
années passées et c'était un de mes
points de désaccord notamment avec avec
pierre moscovici et d'autres c'était
vous n'avez pas eu un désaccord
il y avait beaucoup de désaccords et on
ne mettait pas le paquet sur la
structuration véritablement de la
filière et c'est ça qu'il faut faire si
on veut répondre aux besoins sinon on va
continuer à faire venir des tomates bio
du sud de l'italie et ça c'est à contre
sens et écologique et économique
alors je voudrais bien qu'on parle
maintenant d'une la dynamisation du
centre ville marie et noëlle biguinet
vous avez un projet pour le château de
montbéliard le château des ducs de
wurtemberg dont vous voulez en faire un
coeur touristique culturelle peut-être
un hôtel accessible avec des ascenseurs
pour quoi redonner cette place là au
château
et bien parce que nous avons une
merveilleuse opportunité avec le départ
prochain du conservatoire qui va donc
quitter le site du château pour aller un
petit peu plus bas en ville dans le
quartier des blanches riz et que bien
sûr ce très beau site du château
d'environ trois hectares doit être
réutilisés de manière à attirer une
population nouvelle qu'elle soit locale
ou qu'elles viennent de l'extérieur et
aujourd'hui notre château était
uniquement un château à visée culturelle
et la culture elle est impérative dans
ce lieu mais elle doit s'ouvrir aussi à
quelque chose de plus populaires
c'est-à-dire au tourisme
nous avons le pays de montbéliard
embellir et le pays de montbéliard à des
atours ont des atouts extraordinaires
l'histoire de notre passé avec
l'allemagne et le bureau ambert notre
histoire religieuse qui découlent de ce
passé avec l'allemagne du protestantisme
du protestantisme l'histoire bien sûr le
rebond industriel et donc tout ça ce
sont des atouts monsieur lançons que
pensez vous du projet de madame dîner le
projet évidemment il faut que le château
vive château s'est pas uniquement une
duchesse qui est là donc nous aussi on a
des noces on a des projets évidemment
donc pour le faire vivre au quotidien
pour déjà une accessibilité
il faut déjà le faire vivre au quotidien
donc
une terrasse entre autres il faut
enlever la voiture
là je suis entièrement d'accord avec
votre question tout à l'heure il faut
faire un tiers lieux et c'est à dire
quelque chose de novateur parce que ce
château c'est avant toute chose pour
recentrer culturellement le château sur
l'invention
il faut que tout ce qui a trait à
mandeure retourne à mandeure et tout ce
qui a trait sur la faune et la flore
alala domaine mandeure c'est quoi c'est
le boulot de l'archéologie elle aussi
une grande collection au musée
donc il faut spécialisés le château sur
les inventeurs il faut qu'ils rayonnent
donc avec l'agglomération avec les
autres lieux que jeune il faut qu'il
soit attirant il faut qu'ils vivent
quotidiennement l'hôtel je ne suis pas
d'accord sur un hôtel pour avoir discuté
avec les hôteliers resteront va accepter
d'avoir des concurrents n'ont pas du
tout ils sont non non il travaille pour
le il travaille pour le commun non non
pas du tout il faut que je vive
ascenseur vous faut des qualités que je
veux savoir le pourquoi pas mais
apparemment faire l'ascenseur qu'est ce
qu'on y met quoi
alors on va dire je termine simplement
une toute petite phrase il faut par
contre que les montbéliardais l'intègre
aussi dans la construction donc par
exemple un conseil de quartier
uniquement par quartier conseil de
projet doit être fait tout de suite donc
si je suis maire c'est cela que je vais
faire c'est à dire qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire de notre château de nice
maire vous vous le voyez comment ce
château dans dix ans dans 20 ans si vous
êtes maire de montbéliard
mais je veux en faire un grand espace
pour pour la création frontil enfantine
enfantine pourquoi parce que d'abord la
toutes les activités culturelles la
peinture le théâtre la sculpture etc
je souhaite vraiment qu'on mette le
paquet dans nos écoles sur ces sujets là
et les enfants dans les écoles à la mjc
cetera bailly créer des oeuvres et je
pense que au château il faut qu'on ait
un espace qui soit un espace de
valorisation de la création fantine
pourquoi parce que c'est d'une part pour
les enfants extrêmement important de
pouvoir découvrir leurs oeuvres dans un
endroit absolument
magnifique et en même temps pour les
parents c'est un moyen de se rassembler
de se retrouver autour d'activités qui
sont particulièrement intéressantes mais
je crois que il faut aussi penser le
champ tôt avec son environnement est le
premier environnement du château en
réalité c'est la rue de belfort et je
crois qu'il faut qu'on organise aussi le
la mutation de la rue de belfort en tout
cas peut-être le retour aux sources de
la rue de belfort qu'était une rue très
commerçante une rue des artisans d'art
et moi j'ai envie de recréer tout cela
pour élargir nos centres villes augmente
et améliorer notre offre commerciale
faire que quelqu'un qui vient à à
montbéliard ou centre ville puissent y
passer l'après-midi découvrir des choses
extraordinaires
on a besoin de ça il faut vraiment
l'animé elle anime et ça passe aussi par
exemple par l'installation de plusieurs
kiosque à musique / sur le territoire là
aussi beaucoup fait donner la parole aux
artistes et notamment aux jeunes
créateurs sur notre ville je voudrais
qu'on parle aussi doc très rapidement
vous avez un problème sur montbéliard
c'est le manque de collège je sais bien
que ce n'est pas une compétence
municipale alors qu'elles sont à madame
et messieurs les mesures que vous
aimeriez prendre pour justement lutter
comme sur cette surpopulation des
collèges
madame du guinness et vous la maire
sortante je vous donne la parole oui
alors le grand regret qui est le mien
c'est que 1 des collèges de la petite
hollande était fermé il y a quelques
années j'étais à l'époque la seule élue
à m'opposer à la fermeture de ce collège
tout le monde trouvait que c'était très
mal aujourd'hui vous proposez là
aujourd'hui et bien je crois qu'à un
nouveau collège va être construit
prochainement sur la commune de
bethoncourt il accueillera à la fois des
enfants de bethoncourt et de montbéliard
et que le temps que ce collège construit
soit construit et bien les enfants et
les élèves
du quartier de la petite lande de loups
blazer devons être accueillis dans des
conditions qui restent à définir et qui
ne sont pas forcément évidentes mais ça
sera le choix du conseil départemental
et au bout de quelques années en
construction du nouveau collège de
bethoncourt il faudra faire un bilan des
effectifs pour voir si un nouveau
collège supplémentaire donc c'est du
batin 3 1 plus en voilà sera à
reconstruire ou non messieurs si vous
êtes maire de montbéliard comment vous
fait quel poids vous peser auprès du
département rapidement monsieur
l'ensemble ce que j'aimerais qu'on parte
après sur record sur pm alors mis en
place tout de suite comme il avait été
fait jusqu en 2015 au groupe collège sur
pays de montbéliard agglomération c'est
à dire que le conseil général de
l'époque donc le nouveau conseil
départemental doit mettre rapidement en
place il
il aurait dû le faire d'ailleurs un plan
collège parce que c'est un jeu de cartes
si on enlève des élèves un endroit si on
armés dans l'autre on bouscule
l'équilibré général donc ça c'est la
première chose à faire dans l'urgence
ensuite il faut rassurer les habitants
de la petite hollande parce que ça fait
trois mois qu'on a découvert ce problème
alors que ça fait trois ans qu'il existe
ce problème donc le conseil
départemental obligatoire mois avec sa
vice présidente qui est dans l'équipe de
monsieur summer elle aurait dû prendre
en charge
madame le maire depuis trois mois à
trouver une solution faut pas jouer
comme ça avec les habitants alors
d'affaires répondre de l'ismer
rapidement des semaines très sincèrement
on nage en pleine hypocrisie parce que
la décision qui a été prise de fermer
d'abord un collège à la petite hollande
elle été prise par des amis proches
d'eric lanson et à l'époque
moi j'avais dit en désaccord avec le
plan collèges et j'avais défendu auprès
de claude jeannerot l' idée d'accoler
l'ancien président selon trial du
département de rands 1 d'un collège
supplémentaires en plus de celui qui
devait être construit à bethoncourt
pourquoi parce que moi j'ai pris le
temps de lire cela c'est l'étude de l'
agence d'urbanisme sur l'évolution des
populations scolaires pour les années
qui viennent et on sait tous que le
collège de bethoncourt ne répondra pas
aux besoins
on a besoin d'un nouveau collège et je
pense qu'il faut qu'il soit sur
montbéliard c'était mon avis avant c'est
toujours mon avis aujourd'hui et je
pense qu'on a un terrain aujourd'hui qui
est sur le triangle du congo qui a un
terrain extrêmement vaste
qui est propriété de l'agglomération qui
pourrait même être mis à disposition
très rapidement et si la décision
politique est prise par le département
la réalisation de ce collège peut se
faire très vraiment très rapidement dans
la période à venir
je rajoute quand même le sait pour
répondre aux problèmes de sureffectifs a
dit sureffectif à guynemer à sochaux il
y en a partout dans autour de
montbéliard on a livré un sujet sur
lequel je vais insister
on a 100 à 150 décrocheurs sur
l'ensemble du collège
moi je peux pas accepter la recherche
sont les jeunes complet au collège qui
vont plus au collège ils ont pu aller
qui sont prises que la de manière
vraiment très intermittent
moi je peux pas accepter que des gammes
à se sacrifier de cette manière et je
pense que ce collège supplémentaire que
je que je revendique
je pense qu'il aurait aussi vocation à
accueillir les gamins qui sont en
difficulté scolaire pour qu'on puisse
les remettre dans le circuit sion s'en
occupe pas eh bien on les retrouvera
peut-être à la chiffogne en train de
faire des bêtises
donc il faut s'occuper de ces gamins
absolument et orienter ce collège autour
de la culture scientifique et technique
j'en ai parlé avec monsieur le recteur
je peux vous dire que cette analyse ils
la partagent très largement
on va passer maintenant à l'ap à la pas
dire un mot sur les collègues non
puisqu'on va on va il reste un peu plus
de dix minutes d'émission je suis désolé
madame biguinet donc on va parler de la
présidence de pays montbéliard
agglomération
le président actuel si charles de
bougies les républicains comme vous mr
de fesches-le-châtel vous avez été en
désaccord avec lui notamment sur
l'implantation du conservatoire vous
avez obtenu le conservatoire à
montbéliard mais à quel prix vous avez
dû verser pas mal d'argent
est ce que est ce que si vous êtes réélu
maire de montbéliard
cette fois-ci vous voudrez de la
présidence de pma est ce que vous allez
briguait cette présidence là alors je
vais déjà vous parlez du conservatoire
puisque c'est vous qui avez évoqué le
sujet en disant ça a coûté cher
oui et non la ville nommée milano la
ville de montbéliard 2 4 millions
d'euros à l'agglomération mais en
contrepartie a été votée à
l'agglomération à l'unanimité c'est à
dire que les trois élus communautaires
que nous sommes longue
notez aussi vous êtes d'accorder quoi
sur quelque chose une contrepartie
financière de 3 millions d'euros pour la
rénovation du château
simplement les sommes seront en différé
et puis j'ajoute que le terrain sur
lequel le conservatoire va être
construit nous le vendons à
l'agglomération pour un peu plus de
300000 euros
donc si vous faites 4 - troyes - troyes
c'est là son minutes ira si un peu plus
de 600000 euros
donc il faut aux îles que vous en tirez
pas si mal que ça m'est absolument alors
ab-so-lu-ment la présidence il la
voulait ou pas d'alema je les dis et je
les écris oui je briguerai cette fois ci
la présidence de l'agglomération de pma
je pense que je ne serai pas la seule
que nous serons d'ailleurs de nombreux
candidats à la brigue et de gauche de
droite du milieu ou d'ailleurs et puis
nous verrons bien voilà six ans mère
j'ai mon expérience de maire de la ville
centre
les choses en 2014 était différente
d'aujourd'hui puisque c'est marcel
bonnot qui représentait la ville de
montbéliard qui a été élu président il
représentait bien sûr la ville centre
ensuite il est parti les choses ont été
un peu différente
à l'époque mais voilà où on va poser la
même question éric lançon s'il 22 mars
vous êtes mais bon c'est évidemment
parce qu'on a vécu deux mandatures de
suite sur cette nouvelle agglomération
qui ont été tragiques pour la ville de
montbéliard parce que par le
conservatoire j'ai voté contre
conservatoire non pas pour son accueil
puisque j'étais pour qu'ils soient au
centre-ville en 2010 mais la manière
dont passe dans cela s'est fait quoi
c'est à dire que on a vécu pendant trois
ans une opposition frontale entre le
président d'agglomération et la ville de
montbéliard est de la même couleur
politique jsui lisa pour les
téléspectateurs qui sont pas au courant
de l'histoire montbéliard net vous
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous qui pâtit de
tous la basse et les habitants de
montbéliard
parce que vous avez parlé du léman vous
savez parler vous serez candidat à la
présidence voilà vous le dites cartonné
non non non je voulais juste vous faire
réfléchir
maintenant je sais j'ai occupé tout
n'est qu'en vf bien sûr parce qu'on peut
plus on peut plus
on peut plus opposées comme cela à la
ville et l'agglomération on peut plus
l'opposé et c'est une nouvelle
agglomération de 72 communes 72 avec un
au type de gouvernance on n'est plus
dans le pma 29 ou la ville de willard un
point important donc à tout est à
refaire parce qu'on a vécu pendant trois
ans sur des problèmes maintenant ses 146
mille habitants 638 1845
heureusement ça baisse aussi voilà
encore un indicateur pour dire qu'il
faut absolument que pma soit autrement
gouverner avec une autre manière de
gouverner parce que vous avez cités
madame le maire le conservatoire mais je
vous citez le parvis de la gare
je vais vous citer les alentours de
l'office de tourisme c'est tout le tfc
n'est ce donc une relance est très gros
niveau tel projet là et c'est la ville
qui a payé
pourquoi parce qu'à un moment donné il
ya des bisbilles qui font que au lieu de
voir une vision globale concertée entre
la ville et l'agglomération et bien la
ville je crois qu a été le grand perdant
de ce mandat là denis sommaire la
présidence de pma j'ose même pas vous
poser la question si vous y rêver
puisque vous avez déjà été candidat il
ya trois ans vous avez été candidat
malheureux face à charles demouge donc
vous êtes d'accord avec madame biguinet
et monsieur lançons au moins sur ce plan
là
si vous vous êtes maire de montbéliard
vous êtes aussi candidat à la présidence
oui juste une remarque quand même
l'intention de les régulations j'ai cru
comprendre que que dans votre liste il y
avait des candidats qui soutenait une
autre candidature qui était une
candidature plus hautain courtoise mais
bon peut-être que j'ai mal entendu il
faut il faut décrypter la halle à ce que
vous êtes en train de dire que c'est
certains membres de la liste de monsieur
lançons qui sont socialistes et qui
soutiennent un autre socialiste sur le
pays de montbéliard candidat à la mairie
de d'un co et qui s'appelle martial
bourquin seul et qui va quitter le sénat
pour essayer donc de conserver aux
dindes a fait donc ça va être un débat
intéressant on alterne j'imagine oui je
pense que le maire de montbéliard doit
être président de l'agglo ou une raison
toute simple
c'est la ville centre elles tirent en
réalité l'ensemble de l'agglomération
c'est la ville sont quelque part qui
donne le tempo et quand on regarde de
l'extérieur une agglomération on regarde
sa vie centre et c'est la ville centre
qui par son rayonnement fait rayonner ou
si l'ensemble de l'agglomération
si vous voulez de la être maire de
montbéliard
juste pour être non a dit m pas du tout
pas de doute pas du tout non non non non
non parce que je sais que pour que ça
marche à l'agglomération
il faut qu'il y ait une politique très
audacieuse en matière d'animation de
développement urbain de développement
économique de développement touristique
d'animation de la ville eux à
montbéliard à mon délire et donc ça
croyez moi j'y serai totalement investi
madame biguinet vous êtes donc les
républicains pour le deuxième tour à
montbéliard fou comptait récupérer des
voix ou et bien je compte récupérer les
voix des montbéliardais que j'aurais su
convaincre par déjà le bilan que nous
avons et nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses pendant ces six ans notamment
récupéré une situation financière
catastrophique qui nous a permis ensuite
de relancer des projets attendez j'ai
besoin de poser aussi deux trois petites
questions politiques
éric lançon je sais que denis sommet
vous a déjà tendu la main est ce que en
tant que vous pour un accord de
désistement entre les deux tours qu'est
ce que vous dites moi je jure on s'est
rencontrés on appris de cheveux qui sont
plus parallèle maintenant la politique
que denis sommer défend elle met à mal
25 % des habitants de montbéliard
il ya neuf mille six cents habitants
montbéliard qui ont des aides au
logement par exemple voilà dans l'est
dans les deux quartiers politique de la
ville 1 milliards virés 1,2 milliard
d'économies sur ses aides au logement va
vont obligatoirement impacter ses
habitants là donc là vous êtes en train
de viser donc le représentant du
gouvernement de la république en marche
je suis monsieur
le député justement monsieur débris c
est son cediv estime monsieur dit
monsieur le député ce que c'est
difficile de porter une étiquette la
république en marche en ce moment
l'exemple de l'apl par exemple c'est le
contre exemple
la réalité c'est qu'il ya eu oui une
baisse des appels pour même temps que
été répercutée sur le loyer que voilà
les organismes logeurs ont réduit leur
leur loyer c'est ça la réalité donc les
25 % de population sanctionné c'est pas
vrai voilà tout simplement ce n'est pas
vrai et quand on regarde l'augmentation
des minima sociaux ou l'augmentation de
l'ensemble de nos de la prime d'activité
et cetera on voit bien qu'il ya des
efforts importants ont été faits dans la
dernière période
concernant le cheminement concernant le
deuxième tour voix j'ai fait je renonce
pour toujours aux accords de partie tout
ça je sais que ça marche pas que ça
marche plus et que à force d'additionner
des contraire des gens qui ne
s'entendent sur rien et c'est la réalité
en fait de la liste d'eric ans on est
bien on finit au bout de cinq mois
voilà les choses de marché alors qu'il
restait moins de deux minutes vous aurez
donc chacun 30 secondes pour conclure
donc on avait dit dans le
l'ordre le bas morte que tout à l'heure
qu'on a commencé
denis sommaire c'est à vous de conclure
en 30 secondes top chrono en 30 secondes
et ben écoutez ça fait des mois
maintenant qu'avec eux mon équipe on
travaille d'arrache-pied sur le
programme que nous sommes en train de
diffuser au porte à porte
c'est un programme audacieux de très
très grande qualité qui émanent vraiment
des discussions qu'on a pu avoir avec
les gens et je suis persuadé qu'avec une
équipe d'une telle qualité avec un
premier adjoint qui sera allé que ce
alexandre bergeaud l'un à mes côtés nous
ferons de l'excellent travail pour les
montbéliardes et marie-noëlle biguinet
vos trente secondes à vous voilà et bien
je souhaite continuer ce que nous avons
commencé depuis six ans au service des
mambé liardet en étant à leur côté en
vivant à leurs côtés en continuant à
développer les beaux projets que nous
avons pour tous les quartiers de la
ville de montbéliard puisque je suis
mère de tous les montbéliardais de tous
les montbéliardais zh et que je leur dis
à très bientôt
éric lançon mais la liste que j'ai
constitué est à l'image de notre ville
une liste diversit diverses comme la
ville et diversifiée le sport m'a permis
de ne pas tricher de me dépasser la
culture profit de pse dépasse je traduis
voilà moi il n'y a pas que moi qui suis
sportif à la culture m'a permis de
m'ouvrir aux autres l'éducation m'a
permis de m'élever aussi et puis surtout
de comprendre le monde
je vais mettre en avant toutes ces
valeurs d'exigence démocratique toutes
ces valeurs du vision toutes mes valeurs
et ma liste et s'est terminée sur ces
valeurs là doivent convaincre l'ensemble
des habitants de montbéliard
merci eric lançon et donc je vous laisse
voir le nom des quatre candidats qui
sont engagées au premier tour de
l'élection municipale donc à montbéliard
premier tour le 15 mars 2e tour le 22
mars
il me reste à vous dire merci aux uns et
aux autres
merci madame merci messieurs d'avoir
participé à ce débat d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
nous on se donne rendez vous dans cinq
secondes vraiment cinq secondes pas plus
pour la suite de notre soirée spéciale
élections municipales avec cette fois ci
le débat consacré à la ville de lons le
saunier ville préfecture du jura
un débat qui a été enregistré cet après
midi à tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir à ceux qui nous rejoignent pour
cette soirée spéciale élections
municipales après montbéliard place
maintenant au débat consacré à la ville
de lons le saunier la ville préfecture
du jura jacques pélissard le maire rpr
puis ump pu l air depuis 1989 2